i I advised students as much as possible
look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job here's the key
learn from every mistake be prepared to
be misunderstood anyone working on a big
vision is gonna get called crazy even if
you end up right
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world so help you on your
journey today we're gonna learn the best
advice that all students need to hear
enjoy tip number one is don't sleepwalk
through life with Warren Buffett I
I advise students as much as possible
look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job I mean you know
don't sleepwalk through life but don't
don't say it's all gonna be great you
know I'll do this and I'll do that you
know I'm just marking time to get to be
older that I've told people that's like
saving up sex for your old age I mean it
just is not a it's not a good idea yeah
[Applause]
what are you urging them to do guess
what I'm talking about it just yeah you
really want to be doing what you love
doing and you can't necessarily find it
on your first job right but don't give
up before you find it tip number two is
learn to think critically with Jordan V
Peterson the best thing you can do is
teach people to write because there's no
difference between that and thinking and
one of the things that just blows me
away about universities is that no one
ever tells students why they should
write something it's like well you have
to do this assignment well why are you
writing well you need the great it's
like no you need to learn to think
because thinking makes you act
effectively in the world thinking makes
you win the battles you undertake and
those could be battles for good things
if you can think and speak and write you
are absolutely deadly nothing can get in
your way so that's why you learn to
write it's like why I can't believe that
people aren't just told that it's it's
it's like it's the most powerful weapon
you can possibly provide someone with
and I mean I know lots of people who
have been staggeringly successful and
watched them throughout my life I mean
those people you don't want to have an
argument with them they'll just slash
you into pieces and then not in a
malevolent way it's like if you're gonna
make your point and they're gonna make
their point you better have your points
organized because otherwise you're gonna
look like and be an absolute idiot you
are not gonna get anywhere and if you
can formulate your arguments coherently
and make a presentation if you can speak
to people if you can lay out a proposal
god people give you money they give you
opportunities you have influence tip
number three learn from every mistake
with Oprah Winfrey this is what I want
to share it doesn't matter how far you
might rise at some point you are bound
to stumble because if you're constantly
doing what we do
raising the bar if you are constantly
pushing yourself higher higher the law
of averages not to mention the myth of
Icarus predicts that you will at some
point fall and when you do I want you to
know this remember this there is no such
thing as failure failure is just life
trying to move us in another direction
now when you're down there in a hole it
looks like failure so this past year I
had to spoon-feed those words to myself
and when you're down in the hole when
that moment comes it's really okay to
feel bad for a little while give
yourself time to mourn what you think
you may have lost but then here's the
key learn from every mistake because
every experience encounter and
particularly your mistakes are there to
cheat you and force you into being more
of who you are and then figure out what
is the next right move and the key to
life is to develop an internal moral
emotional GPS that can tell you which
way to go tip number four work on
yourself
with Kevin O'Leary I was working once in
an ice-cream parlor when I was about 15
years old my first real job and on the
second day I was asked to scrape the gum
off between the Mexican tiles on the
floor and I said to the woman who owned
the storms called Magoo's ice cream
parlor you didn't hire me to scrape gum
you hired me to scoop ice cream and this
this girl in the shoe store across the
way that's looking at me I don't want to
see her me scraping the gum and she said
what are you talking about I own this
store I'll do anything I want with you
get down on your knees and scrape that
gum when I said I'm not doing it
she said you're fired last job I ever
had I owe that woman everything
I don't like to work for people many of
you would hear I hope and inherit that
there's nothing wrong with it
if you want to control your own destiny
you work for yourself that's how it
works I'm trying to inspire those of you
are on the tipping point take the chance
you're young go for it
there's nothing better than being able
to wake up in the morning 10 years or 20
years so now and do what ever you like
it it's about freedom that's what
matters
I'm not saying being an employee's bad
but believe me being an entrepreneur is
better I'm a little bias tip number five
attack what you love with Gary
Vaynerchuk if you are 22 years old and
graduating from college if you're 22
years old and not graduating from
college if you are 22 years old you were
entering first of all some of the
greatest years of your life a but be
this this is the moment watch this video
twice if Mama's watching this send this
to your daughter Sally right now because
you have to understand this next
five-year window is when you don't go
practical and safe this is not the time
to get the job mom wanted you to this is
not the time to try to maximize as much
money so you can buy a fat whip this is
the time to realize that you have a
five-year window and it's three for some
it's eight for others but there's a fine
new window for you to attack the life
that you want to win not because it's
the secret or cuz the world so Zen
because it's hardest out there as a
matter of fact I'm probably more scared
about your naivete to how hard class is
easy right what you've been doing for
the last 16 years is easy it's a
[ __ ] game it's structured it's easy
the world this thing this thing is hard
however that contradicts what I'm going
to tell you right now which is this is
the best
and easiest five years of your life
because this is when you need to attack
what you love and what you want to do
here's why you don't have all the
baggage you may have college loans
respect it's hardest you may have the
expectations of your parents mentally
hard fake hard you may have a lot of
other things but this is exactly when
you can live with four roommates in a
basement and eat fast food do you
understand this is not when the baby's
there some of your babies this is not
when you've been married and you
promised this is not when the world has
sucked out all your dreams and hopes yet
you still got this window and yet so
many of you are so hungry for short-term
short-term gains like maximizing the job
that paid you $3,000 more but it's not
as fun but you want that $3,000 for what
for what for a new iPhone for what you
get to live life one time and this is
the time right now to understand what's
actually happening and actually map your
behavior to something that will impact
you for the next 80 years so promise me
promise me all you youngsters that are
watching this right now in the comments
because I'll jump in and talk to you
promise me that you understand that the
land grab of happiness starts right now
now you don't have to worry about
getting that job what you should do is
go and travel and learn go and start
that business that you've always wanted
hook up with those three teammates and
start that band you've always wanted
this is the time to be massively risk
massively risk oriented I know that this
is when you're supposed to grow up and
go see the world
but guess what the world isn't what
mommy and daddy told you the world is
exactly going to be what its going to be
with or without the way you thought it
was going to be a ton of is gonna change
the world changes every goddamn day
right now what you need to recognize is
you can afford to tip number six be
prepared to be misunderstood with Mark
Zuckerberg it's really good to be
idealistic but be prepared to be
misunderstood anyone working on a big
vision is going to get called crazy even
if you end up right
anyone taking on a complex problem is
gonna get blamed for not fully
understanding it even though it's
impossible to know everything up front
anyone taking initiative will always get
criticized for moving too fast because
there's always someone who wants to slow
you down tip number seven take risks
with Natalie Portman people told me that
Black Swan was an artistic risk a scary
challenge to try to perforate portray a
professional ballet dancer but it didn't
feel like courage or daring that drew me
to it
I was so oblivious to my own limits that
I did things I was woefully unprepared
to do and so the very inexperienced that
in college had made me feel insecure and
made me want to play by other's rules
now was making me actually take risks I
didn't even realize were risks when
Darren asked me if I could do ballet I
told him that I was basically a
ballerina which by the way I
wholeheartedly believed when it quickly
became clear and preparing for the film
that I was maybe 15 years away from
being a ballerina it made me work a
million times harder and of course the
magic of cinema and body doubles helped
the final effect but the point is if I
had known my own limitations I never
would have taken the risk and the risk
led to one of my greatest artistic and
personal experiences and that I not only
felt completely free I also met my
husband during filming tip number eight
learn before you earn with Tim Ferriss
what would my advice be to a driven and
intelligent college student or young
person about to enter the real world
well I would be very simple it would be
focus on learning instead of earning and
that sounds cliched but I'll explain why
because if you want to make say a
million dollars a year ten million
dollars a year instead of a hundred
thousand dollars a year I would argue
you probably don't want to take the
hundred thousand dollar per year job
even if it's offered to you right out of
the gate that sounds like a lot of money
but what I'm going to recommend is not
limited to finances you want to focus on
projects on companies on environments
where you can learn lessons on
someone else's bankroll alright so let
them pay for it and view it effectively
as an apprenticeship so find a situation
where you can be in the room with
masters of a craft and that could just
be deal making it could be joining a
small company say a fewer than 50 people
where you simply get to observe one of
the principles negotiating in an
industry that you don't even care
anything about right it could be waste
management and you want to go into
hi-tech but if you sit in a room with
someone who's an absolute pro at
crafting deals negotiating getting past
know those skills and maybe those
relationships start to snowball all
right and this is what scott adams the
creator and Dilbert would call systems
thinking so instead of being wedded to
the outcome of a given job you are
accumulating skills and relationships
that transcend that job okay and if you
choose your environments well because as
I've said before and as people like Drew
the CEO of Dropbox as a friend have said
you're the average of the five people
you associate with most alright so if
you take just a few years have the
patience a few years to really develop
core competencies that allow you to
craft your own reality and life
negotiation deal-making getting past
know etc learning how to pitch how to
get someone's attention in 30 seconds so
that you can then create the desire and
ultimately ask for some type of action
once you develop those then you can
really just create the map for the next
decade in the next several decades so
that would be it it would be learned
before you earn and it's never too late
to do that so I don't care if you're
coming out of college coming out of high
school
30 40 whatever it is systems thinking
focus on the skills and relationships
first and then you can just create a
blank check for how much money you want
to make if that is your goal
for nine the last one before the bonus
is bringing your dreams to life with
Denzel Washington my wife told me this
great expression to get something you
never had you have to do something you
never did les Brown's a motivational
speaker you made an analogy about this
he says imagine you're on your deathbed
and standing around your deathbed are
the ghosts representing your unfulfilled
potential the ghosts of the ideas you
never acted on the ghosts of the talents
you didn't use and they're standing
around your bed angry disappointed and
upset they say we came to you because
you could have brought us to life they
say and now we have to go to the grave
together so I ask you today how many
ghosts are going to be around your bed
when your time comes
now I have a special bonus clip for you
from Jeff Bezos but before getting to
that my question of the day today is
what is the single best piece of advice
that you have ever received that is have
an impact on you
what is that best piece of advice
leaving the comments below I'm excited
to see what you have to say thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
decided to do this I I first talked to
my my wife who is sitting here in the
audience and she had married a you know
relatively stable to goofy
but still relatively stable a person
working at a Wall Street firm I worked
at a quantitative hedge fund and this
was a hard decision and I was looking
for the right framework in which to make
that kind of important decision and and
and and and the right framework I found
is a regret minimization framework and I
said that's just a nerdy way of saying
that you want to project yourself to age
80 and then think back over your life
and and if you're if you're if you're 81
or the thew want to minimize the number
of regrets you have throughout that
period of time I think this is something
a lot of people do maybe subconsciously
they probably very few people probably
name it regret minimization framework
because most people are healthier than
that but but it was a very clear way for
me to think about making that kind of
life decision and the and in the way it
helped was I thought okay if I go do
this thing and participate in this thing
called the Internet that I genuinely
believe is gonna be a big deal and if I
fail am I gonna regret having tried and
failed and I knew the answer that was no
but I also knew that if I didn't try
that I would always regret that I would
always wonder and it would haunt me and
until that you know mythical day which I
actually hope will come
[Music]
the most important work ever if you have
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]